[Music]
well I'm our Stevie Moore I'm generally
known as one of the main pioneers of low
fidelity one-man band home recording
I've been recording for 50 something
years and I've made 400 albums in my
home
[Music]
and now our Stevie more prolific mr.
Stevie Moore our Stevie Moore yes I am
our Stevie Moore back when I was a
younger child I started my own idea of
home recording by myself my father was a
bass player doing all the country
sessions with all the stars of Nashville
I had access to tape recorders in my
teenage basement and I was a huge rock
and roll fan and absorbed all of these
influences I started messing around with
writing songs and making my own music do
you record the privacy of your own home
is that correct that's right now how do
you do that well late sixties is when I
started making my little albums I / dub
all the instruments myself I play bass
and guitars and keyboards and percussion
and vocals I got really good at it I'm
deuce seven eight nine tan overdubs and
you'd still hear the very first thing
that I used did you invent home
recording of course not but I took it to
another level long before it was
customary I've probably written about
four or five thousand songs they came
out effortlessly I would compile the
most recent songs I wouldn't pick and
choose the best ones and throw the worst
ones on the floor and that's been my
aesthetic all along it's like everything
is released warts and all because bad
music is brilliant it's a diary of sound
everybody that has ever been a record
collector loves to turn their pals on
the obscure why do you hear this one I
mean I do have that reputation talking
heads and b-52s and we're all fans of
mine naturally a lot of these big
artists have found my music just word of
mouth but they never saw me because I
was the home hermit
[Music]
to improve the quality I've hardly ever
performed and I was a bedroom guy it was
always get home put the headphones on
and then I would work for hours and
hours in 2010 things started to explode
out of nowhere suddenly I was in a band
and touring the world
I was playing hard rock shows big
festivals and tiny dives is incredible
my career really started taking off a
little too late in life often people say
I can't see how you've done this same
thing all this time without falling
through the trap and by avoiding the
mainstream nobody is gonna dare tell me
what I can and can't do feel so good to
have that integrity intact I'm proud of
all that and I'm also still a little kid
you
[Music]